turns out battlefield one has a game
mode other than conquest no surprise
there at e3 dice showed off a mode not
new to the series called domination and
it's still just as straightforward two
teams fight to hold capture flags
holding a flag generates tickets the
more flags your team holds the more
tickets your team breaks in basically
its infantry only conquest on a smaller
map and there's really not much else to
it capture defend sure it comes off as a
planned bare-boned experience yet my
main takeaway was a stronger sense of
not just what battlefield once infantry
combat entails but where teamwork and
purpose lies within each class the map
was the same as the one seen in conquest
gameplay Sam Quinton just the town
portion essentially meaning that you're
running into the enemy at practically
every step and if that didn't keep you
on your toes battlefield ones
destructible environment is in full
swing doors walls fences are all
practically unreliable you find yourself
rating cover based on the material used
do I put my life in the hands of a
wooden door or this concrete wall the
choice is obvious and the same
disruption goes hand in hand when you're
chasing that kill oh I see you found a
nice wooden door to hide behind how's
that working out for you in the heat of
the moment you're devoting your precious
time into environmental knowledge if an
enemy is behind would shoot if he's
behind a concrete wall use an anti-tank
grenade and shake things up speaking of
shaking things up battlefield ones
dynamic weather is in full swing here
once that fog rolls in so does the close
quarters combat it's strongly advised
you put away that sniper in favor of a
shoddy or SMG and shotgun fans like
myself will love the fog that fog brings
forth those risky moves like dashing
across the street in order to flank a
foe it's a well-fitting changeup
especially when it occurs at random
aesthetically domination really hits the
soldier chords for me and not just
battlefield 1942 but the world war 2
cinematic grit as a whole yes World War
2 I said it but let's face it this is
what battlefield one is and I'm
personally all for it because it works
so well you get flashbacks of Jackson
from saving private ryan and as a medic
i instinctively dashed under fire to go
for that revived fully comfortable with
the circumstances especially with the
heavy implementation of squads you
weren't just spawning on your teammates
you felt the drive to stick with
typically I place shooters as the
dickish lone wolf but here I strive to
huddle next to my teammate under mg fire
busting open barn doors and clearing
houses couple this with dices superb
sound design you really do feel like
you're living in a breathing war flick
and by the way busting open doors and
clearing houses were easily the most
tense and gripping moments of my entire
play all in all as a game-mode
domination was about as simplistic as it
gets yet my takeaway was a game
traveling back to its familiar roofs
with the occasional sprinkling of new
gimmicks like actually seeing practical
use of the poison gas toss it strapped
on a mask and take down the disoriented
enemy these are the gadgets and
mechanics that will really make
battlefield one stand out at the moment
alpha has showed us its core battlefield
one is a remake of a classic World War 2
shooter thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe for more battlefield
one content
you